it's the life of the party Jamila Jamel
[Applause]
hello this head to toe look this is just
for you oh my God I had to show it off
to everybody because I mean I looked
down and I was like oh we need to start
in front of the desk I went full dessert
you you are full dessert now our I am so
excited about your new show She-Hulk
attorney at law
doing the whole interview here now let's
go back at the desk all right here we go
[Applause]
you are now a full on Marvel villain
titanium
I love this show what is it that maybe
is a detail that you can give us about
She-Hulk that we might not know well
look this would not talk about our show
being about misogyny and it's made some
men who haven't even seen it very angry
um and and that's a shame because
misogyny is something that affects
everyone I mean men are killing
themselves at high rates than anyone
else and so patriarchy misogyny these
are things we all need to be talking
about and I actually play the biggest
misogynist in the show as a woman which
is important because we know that women
can be guilty of misogyny yes absolutely
in the audience yeah and I think some
people are just threatened and upset by
a show that is About Women by women
centering women and that's just you know
um can I ask you advice what is one
account that you as such a social media
Advocate and you play a social media
villain I know and then I speak like
this in the show which is really new for
me I just feel like we've never hadn't
like a demonic level villain who also
kind of talks like this you know what I
mean yeah yeah
yeah
so good you sound like you're from the
San Fernando Valley thank you thank you
um what is one platform we should all
follow today starting today I really
like Rich Auntie's Supreme it's a small
account but it's run by Rachel Cargill
who has a huge account on social media
she is a wonderful anti-racist activist
but she's got this account called Rich
Auntie Supreme that is for women who do
not wish to have children I am one of
those women I believe that it does not
make my life sad or empty it means I
sleep in forever and so I uh I love
anything that celebrates women's choice
and People's Choice and if you don't
want to have a baby there's nothing
wrong with you it's a really hard world
and it's totally okay and I'm with you
you can come hang out with me yeah I
love that do you know what I like to
call it what there's motherhood and
other Hood yes all right well will you
had some headlines with us sure
okay so speaking of social media here is
a question are you too quick to block
someone after a breakup refinery29 says
more people are hitting block
immediately after a relationship ends
either romantic or platonic in cases
where there's a serious safety and
wellness concern like in situations of
harassment or abuse or otherwise of
course a block is fully warranted but
outside of that if you're too quick to
block an ex friend or a lover might you
regret it later are you losing out on a
chance for emotional growth Drew Ross
are you too quick to block uh no I'm not
a blocker I think blocking them gives
them too much power yeah I mean they see
that you block they see that you care I
like to mute and then silently stalk
them and I think that you know what I
mean
because if you block you can't look
later yeah agreed thank you by the way
that's true I didn't even think about
that yeah why aren't we just muting
people they'll never know what you're
doing mute mute block delete repeat
there's a bumper sticker
[Applause]
I like your attitude I really do okay
next ever take a selfie and immediately
hate it well apparently there's a
psychological reason in style reports
that it all boils down to expectations
when you first snap a selfie you have
the highest expectation and you want the
picture to Be Perfect all of a sudden
you look at it you see imperfections
you're disappointed but if you let it go
for a few days or weeks guess what it's
like Sands Through The Hourglass you no
longer kind of look at it with that
scrutiny you can look back at the same
photo and think that actually look
pretty darn good how do you think this
happens and why Jamila and Rossi well I
think it's because of the rise of
editing photographs right I get why
people do it it's because Hollywood wood
has put out so many impossible images
for everyone else to try and live up to
that are all photoshopped and now we can
all do it with apps the reason I don't
Photoshop anything and the reason I
don't let Hollywood Photoshop me even my
Marvel poster is completely unedited
it's not because I'm so great and I'm on
my soapbox it's because my mental health
gets damaged when I look in a mirror I
feel disappointed because I'm trying to
live up to an AI perfected image and so
you know they tried to take my back fat
out of an MBC like billboard for the
good place and I was like cut my back
fat back in I insisted that it was like
a boob at my back but I've got one when
I wear strapless dresses because I've
got big boobs this happens don't take
this away I have to live with this don't
take it away temporarily otherwise I'll
start to hate it I'm so with you yeah
well you know what then can we take a
selfie
let's not retouch it no retouch oh ready
oh yeah come on
yo thank you Jamila Jamil Patrick and
She-Hulk attorney at law right now on
Disney plus with new episodes on
Thursdays
[Music]